nous en venons nous revenons donc à
notre invité isabelle adjani qui nous
fait la gentillesse de venir sur ce
plateau ce soir pour les débuts
américains de la reine margot le
chef-d'oeuvre de patrice chéreau
le film part à la conquête des états
unis dans une version un peu plus courte
à la demande des producteurs américains
les critiques cinéma sont très exigeants
aux états unis et ils ont aimé un
extrait on déclare toujours me lever de
mon disque du cancer
le coeur ce kit oreilles mais dans des
boîtes en or
autour d'eux trouve un dessin
et quoi encore
parfois la miray visage ces menaces que
je marquerai bien
à la recherche de l'amour
un jour tu seras maman qui tu es
surmontant une fois vos clichés
parce que je ne suis pas la personne que
tu réduis mes
les chinois
il admis je crois savoir que c'est l'une
des scènes préférées du film l'une de
vos scènes préférées
une scène que j'aime bien steam ses
nouvelles pourquoi vous l'aimez
particulièrement parce que c'est
tellement de serment je suis très
sensible à ça alors je le disais il ya
une soirée de lancement aux etats-unis
apparemment la critique est
dithyrambique vous aviez un petit peu
peur de ça 2 de la ville et des
critiques américains qui sont toujours
féroce et c'est à dire que nous on avait
l'espoir que à chaque fois d'ailleurs où
le même espoir quand on sort un film à
l'étranger qu'ils aient une réception
aussi bonne que possible parce que notre
cinéma français on a besoin puisqu'il
est très très pudique exploité à
l'étranger est finalement très peu de
films peu d'appréhension français sur
sortent chaque année on a peut-être un
petit peu des clichés dans la tête mais
vous pensez que le public américain peut
être réceptif à ce genre de film sur
notre histoire sur l'histoire de france
des films qu'on peut qualifier d' un peu
peut-être difficile où je crois oui
c'est un film qui leur apprend quelque
chose sont des gens curieux et c'est un
film aussi qui est fait avec un esprit
très européen et qui raconte aussi à
travers l'histoire puisque ça se passe
en 472 pas l'histoire de l'europe
aujourd'hui énormément de déco par
rapport aux exigences des producteurs
américains de de raccourcir un petit peu
la première version est ce que c'est pas
à votre avis vous avez joué à l'intérêt
du film n'est pas le metteur en scène
mais un petit peu frustrant finalement
être obligé de couper une première
version non ce coup je crois de patrice
chéreau metteur en scène était tout à
fait disposé à faire ça puisque c'est
quelqu'un qui a l'habitude de théâtre et
de l'opéra et au théâtre l'opéra rock
reprend son travail on reprend sa
création et on n'a pas peur c'était un
film c'est la même chose c'est un
certain matériel matériaux nobles
ça peut aussi avoir une vie souple et il
a trouvé un deuxième souffle pour le
film qui à mon avis est plus romantique
oui vous avez vu les deux autres votre
sentiment
ils ont découvert au milieu du public à
londres au festival de londres où il a
été présenté et j'ai trouvé
rempli de suspense plus haletants pu
plus émouvant ce rôle de la reine margot
et un rôle le formidablement difficile
j'imaginais interprétez vous avez
plusieurs rôles difficiles dans les
derniers films que vous avez fait
camille claudel celui là comment est-ce
que l'on sort de donne un rôle comme
celui de la reine margot c'est pas trop
difficile parce que c'était c'est un
rôle dans all entier c'est un rôle
entier vista rôle très humain c'est à
dire que c'était un rôle
au contraire ce sont les autres
personnages ou avec des tâches très
inhumaines et pour un acteur c'est c'est
un travail difficile
moi j'avais mon rôle c'était de
représenter l'humanité
quelque chose d'humain quelque chose de
généreux quelque chose de le bien et ça
pour moi c'est si facile c'est beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus difficile de se
battre pour interpréter les choses qui
vous font balle en tant qu'être humain
c'est à dire le mal par exemple quels
sont les projets d'isabelle adjani dans
les mois qui viennent ou au cinéma
les projets il existe pour le début de
l'automne prochain seulement et on n'en
parle pas ils sont toujours je crois
qu'il faut toujours les tenir et tenir
secret jusqu'à ce qu'ils prennent vie
merci beaucoup isabelle adjani on va
donc observer avec attention le succès
de la reine margot aux états unis avec
cette nouvelle version qui sort aussi en
france oui demain
merci beaucoup d'avoir été accepté par
notre invitation je suis tout ému
voilà avant de refaire